So King App,
Gar over in the east Syria region,
rights to Jesus saying, I've heard
these great stuff about you. I've got,
I'm a little sick.
Can you come hear me?
I'll provide you know the the
people in Jerusalem don't like you.
You'll find a nice peaceful home here.
Jesus wrote back,
apparently
bless it,
are you for believing in me?
Although you have not seen me
for it as written concerning me,
that those who have seen
me will not believe me and
that those who have not seen
me,
they will believe and be saved.
But concerning what you wrote to me,
namely to come to you.
It is necessary for me to complete here
all for which I was sent and after the
completion to be received
up to him that sent me.
But when I am received up,
I shall send one of my disciples to you
to heal your affliction and to impart
life to you and your people.
There you have it.
Okay,
let her from king ad guarded Jesus
led her to Jesus. Back to King Ahab.
Guard you believe it
kind of go like this or like
this. Come on, take a stand,
go out on a limb,
decide you're just going to do something
wildly crazy and have an opinion.
All right. Do you believe that
those letters are authentic? No.
Does anybody believe they're authentic?
If so,
I've got some land I want to sell you.
Nobody believes that the letters from
King Ab Guard to Jesus are authentic
letters and nobody believes that. The
letter from Jesus to add Gar is authentic.
We believe they are a pig.
Graphy remember we did this before.
What's the meaning of an anonymity?
Which letters?
Which documents? They me a document in
the new testament that is anonymous.
Yeah,
the gospels. Exactly. The names and the
gospels were added by later scribes.
They weren't part of the original doctors,
so they're not suit on him us because
the gospel of Matthew actually doesn't
claim itself to be buying Matthew. It
just is out there. So there are anonymous.
The letter to the Hebrews is anonymous.
It doesn't even claim to be by Paul
or by anybody else that we know of.
It's just a letter
that's there in the text.
I mean the text is just there by itself,
namely a document we've talked
about that is pseudonymous.
Anybody
what
first? Second, Third John.
Actually they don't claim to be by John
that that's again anonymous letters.
We will get to them today.
Pseudonym.
Anonymity means it claims to be
by someone who is not by who?
We just don't believe it's by.
So the letters of Edgar,
the letter of APP to Jesus.
And if Jesus to Ab Gar scholars
call that pseudonymous.
They're written in their names but we
don't believe they actually wrote them.
Now what? Why do you say you don't
believe those letters? Authentic.
I mean obviously the tone of my voice,
I was messing with them.
So that could have tipped you off
and you may think, well you know,
I've just never heard that there was an
actual letter of Jesus of Nazareth that
survives.
So you would think that you would have
heard about that in the New York Times if
there actually was one that was authentic.
But what else about the letters that
you heard might tip you off that there
pseudonomas yes sir.
[inaudible]
exactly. The letters are written in Greek.
So if the letters are written in Greek,
well we don't really have any evidence
that Jesus spoke Greek and if he did,
if he did speak Greek,
he probably didn't write Greek at the
literary level that those letters are
obviously written.
I mean I don't know if you noticed but
there's a certain stylistic next to them
even in the English translation that
sounds like these are written by educated
people. They know how to write
a good letter forms. So Jesus,
we don't know anything
about Chemo Ag Gar much,
but we can certainly say that most
of us don't believe Jesus had kind of
education that he could have
written a great letter like that.
So that's one indication.
Anything else? Yes sir.
Sounds like the gospel of John. It
sounds like the gospel of John. Exactly.
Remember the line that said, some
people have seen me and not believe me,
but it's just almost like a
quotation from the gospel of John.
So you kind of think this sounds like
something that some Christian scribe would
write long after the life of
Jesus and why not? I mean,
if you're a Christian scribe
living in the third century,
some scholars date these letters to
around two 50 year or two 50 or so.
It's a guest. But, um, and if you
were to describe living in the,
around the year two 50 and to you Jesus
is the son of God. He's divine. You know,
he, he, he's this, he's powerful.
He's a miracle. He's the,
he's the emperor of the cosmos,
the world.
And so you kind of think in your popular
mindset, well, why wouldn't other king,
why wouldn't kings who lived during the
time of Jesus have heard about them and
know about him?
What he did,
all these miraculous deeds wouldn't
have been world famous. In fact,
a lot of modern people have the
same idea. They, they, they,
they're very surprised when they
realize that Jesus, actually,
nobody knew anything about him in
his lifetime. And they said, well,
but he did all these miracles
and they're the gospel. Somebody,
these crowds that followed
him in these kinds of things.
Wouldn't that really have made that the
headlines of the time? And you say, well,
there actually were a lot of miracle
workers running around the ancient world.
There are a lot of profits.
There were a lot of people
claiming to raise the dead.
It wasn't that unusual thing.
So no,
Jesus wasn't famous Jersey
during his own lifetime.
But you can imagine how a scribe,
a Christian scribe in the middle of the
third century would naturally think that
this person, he worships as
Lord, must've been famous.
And therefore it's entirely
believable that there could have been
correspondences between Jesus and,
and kings around the world.
And so these letters get made up as
part of just basic Christian piety.
You know, if the letters didn't exist,
they ought to exist. So we'll write them.
We have other examples of
pseudonymity we have for, um,
letters between Paul and
the philosopher Seneca,
which nobody believes they're authentic.
Nobody believes it's the philosopher
Seneca, who was the aid. If you recall,
to the Emperor Nero,
he was an advisor to Nero until he fell
out of favor and neuro kicked him out
and all that sort of thing.
But Seneca,
it was one of the most famous
first century stoic philosophers.
And so there's somebody wrote letters
years later that which Sinica rights to
Paul and says, you know, you are
such a great philosopher, Paul.
I wonder if we could get
together and have little coffee.
Klatch and Paul writes back and says,
I'm really busy right now, but you know,
we've got some. So they write letters back
and forth. We have all kinds of things.
Now you have to, there are also,
these are not just Christian letters.
There are a whole bunch of letters written
under the names of very famous cynic
philosophers. Now, the
word cynic in this context,
it doesn't mean just the adjective,
someone who is cynical and comes from
the Greek word for dog Kunos and certain,
there's a certain philosophical movement,
uh,
in the ancient world in which certain men,
and in a few cases,
women act tried to teach that you should
live completely according to nature.
So for example, if it's natural to, to
eat and have sex, then you shouldn't.
There's nothing shameful about eating
or having sex even in public. Um,
if it's natural for people to follow
their desires and usually just follow your
desires. And so the cynics got called
doggies philosophers by other people,
cause they did the kinds of stuff that
humans don't do in public but dogs do in
public or are they also got the
nickname for several other reasons.
But somebody in late antiquity decided
that they wanted a series of letters that
talk about the philosophy of cynicism.
And so they have letters back and forth
under the names of famous philosophers,
of the cynic movement,
which talk about the morality
of the civic movement or debate,
different issues about
the Senate movement.
So there are all kinds
of letters of Plato.
We have a big difficulty trying to figure
out are all the letters that exist in
ancient Greek manuscripts that claimed
to be letters of the philosopher Plato.
Are they really by Plato? And almost no
scholar believes. They all are by Plato.
There's uh,
some,
many scholars believe that at least some
of the letters that have been passed
down of a tradition, that being
by Plato may really be by Plato,
but certainly not all of them.
So that that phenomenon of
pseudoprogression suit epigraphy,
sue typography,
sue topography,
that his writings under
a false name was very,
very popular in the ancient world.
And we have all kinds of evidences for it.
But now you have to imagine how would
this work? How would, for example,
um, these letters be produced? Well,
I've said Christians might do
it because it's a work of piety.
They think that these, these letters
ought to exist. But then you have to say,
well, how would they have been published?
Remember, we don't have printing presses,
so you can't just send something off
anonymously or a suit honestly to a
publisher and just try to get it
published with the printing press,
everything's done.
One copy by one by hand.
Everything in the ancient world has to
be copied by hand. One letter at a time.
And in fact, they did copy one
letter at a time. This, they, they,
you could tell by reading manuscripts,
they're almost all capital letters and
they're kind of block capital letters and
they don't have spaces between words.
Most of the time they don't have spaces
all between sentences. And so they,
you can tell these scribes copying
one letter at a time often.
And that's why we get so many mistakes.
And our new testament manuscripts,
we have thousands of new
testament manuscripts and
there's not two of them that
are alike. Exactly. There's,
we have more mistakes in new,
in the Greek copies of the New Testament.
Then we even have manuscripts of the
Greek copies in the new testament and
that's in the thousands.
Nobody knows how many mistakes we have
in the Greek new testament in different
manuscripts.
There are so many,
nobody's ever named account them and
it'd be almost impossible to count them.
But the reason we have this,
because it all had to be done
one letter by one letter,
one PR scribe with one scribe
and that's why you haven't,
but you have to imagine then if you want
to publish a letter from King Ad Guard
to Jesus and then a letter from Jesus
back to King Ahab. [inaudible] well,
how do you do it?
Well,
you know you're a scribe so you write up
these letters and then maybe you write
up a few copies and send them around
to people or show them that people are,
or you might claim that you found this
in a library of amount monastery where
you work or you might just send it to a
book's a book seller and get the books
seller to notice it or you might put
it in a page of another manuscript.
Say you're compiling a,
a manuscript,
a book that has the different
gospels and you decide, you know,
I'm going to put this on the back fly
leaf of this book that I'm copying,
so sued epigraphic letters
were distributed and recopied
and passed around the
world and it's not a Christian phenomenon
is not just a Jewish phenomenon.
Everybody was doing it.
Today we get to the first two letters.
We're going to talk about
other Pauline corpus.
Last time we've talked about the
seven undisputed letters of Paul.
Now we're going to get to the time when
we talk about the disputed letters of
Paul.
Remember I've talked about the,
Paul's letters can be divided up into
three camps, the undisputed seven letters,
which are listed. I've only listened
for me, I'm not gonna do it now.
They're also in your textbook.
And then there's the letters
that almost all scholars,
critical scholars believe are
pseudopod suit epigraphic,
which is first and
second Timothy and Titus.
And then there's the disputed letters
that some scholars will accept as being by
Paul and other scholars doubt or by Paul.
And the two that are the most debated
probably now are Colombians and Ephesians
and some people like me say that
they're not written by Paul,
but there's sort of pig suit epigraphic
and some people say they are written by
Paul. Yes sir. The churches,
which are the Roman Catholic Church,
the Roman Catholic Church traditionally
would've said there's no such thing as
sue topography in the Bible.
But that's changed in the 20th century,
especially with Vatican too,
which happens in the 60s. Uh,
the Roman Catholic Council of Vatican too
said that historical criticism as it's
practiced in the 20th century is perfectly
legitimate to practice on the new
testament documents.
So you will even find good faithful Roman
Catholic scholars who will also either
accept or reject the Pauline
authorship of this. So, uh,
the Roman Catholic Church has no official
doctrinal position on the authorship
of the different pieces of the Bible.
They may have at one time just
assumed that everything was written.
Everything that says it's written by
Paul was written by Paul. But, uh,
especially since Vatican two,
Roman Catholic scholars are completely
free to make their own decision about
this based purely on the kinds
of historical and linguistic, uh,
criteria that Protestant scholars use.
Also,
any other questions for I move
on. Okay. Listen to why do we,
why do I say that Cola
collages in Ephesians were
not written by Paul but by a
disciple of Paul later. The main reason
I want to give his writing style,
just like if you turn in a paper to
your teaching fellow and say you're the
first paper that you turned
in early in the semester,
a was written in a certain kind of style
and then you turn in the second paper
and it's in a very different style.
Say it has very elaborate sentences.
Where's your first paper had started?
Straightforward, simple sentences.
It uses lots of dependent clauses where
with whereas your first paper didn't use
so many dependent clauses. Your first
paper used rather simply simple language.
Your second paper uses all this
kind of language and you know, you,
you either have all of a sudden gotten a
real, uh, a different kind of education.
Are you went thesaurus crazy
or something so you're,
you're teaching fellow might say,
I'm getting suspicious that this letter
doesn't look like it's written by the
same person.
We can tell things by writing style.
Now you've read seven letters that we
most almost all scholars believe Paul
actually wrote.
Here's the way Colassians starts out.
This is Collagen's one, three through
eight. If that, get your bibles out.
Follow along with me because what is
our motto for the semester's course?
They omnivorous Doobie,
tandem doubt, everything.
And why do you bring your bibles to class?
Because I'll lie to you exactly.
I'm going to read my own translation
of Collagen's one three through eight.
So notice this is a good five verses.
I Read my translation because you will
notice in your translation that the
editors have have broken
up this one sentence.
This is all one sentence in Greek.
The editors had broken it up into several
different sentences because it just
doesn't read like an English sentence.
So here's what it is. In Greek,
we give thanks to God the
father of our Lord Jesus Christ,
always for you when we pray,
hearing of your faithfulness in Christ
Jesus and the love which you have toward
all the holy ones,
that is the saints because of the hope
laid in store for you in the heavens,
which hope you heard about before in
the word of the truth of the Gospel that
came to you just as
also in all the cosmos.
It is bearing fruit and growing just as
also among you from which day you heard
and recognized the grace of God in truth,
just as you learned from EPA for us,
our beloved coast slave who is your
trustworthy servant of Christ and who also
made clear to us your love in the spirit.
One sentence.
Notice how yours was chopped
up into several other closets
and smaller sentences.
I kept using relative pronouns,
like who did this,
which this and using a ing
words participle because
that's what you use and the
Greek to string along clause
after clause after clause.
Now if you turn in a sentence like this,
expect to get a c on your paper because
this is not good American English
writing style, right? You
recognize that now, didn't
you? Right? Nod your head. Yes,
we recognize that's not good English
riding style in Contemporary America,
but it actually was pretty good
writing style in the 19th century.
Sometimes and you eat older English and
they educated writers will often write
with these complex sentences with
dependent clause, independent clause,
independent clause,
all nestled together.
That's called periodic style a period.
Is this a looping Greek or Latin sentence
that loops around on itself and then
comes into this nice big hole. Um, now
that was a good writing style in Latin.
It was a good writing style
in ancient classical Greek.
And so this writer is actually
riding in a fine style.
There's nothing bad just because our
styles have changed and it's no longer
considered good writing
style in modern English,
but it was good writing
style and in Greek.
And you can recognize it when you read
it in the original Greek in a way that
you can't recognize it so much when you
read it in your English translation.
Now here's the first sentence,
not the first sentence, but uh,
Ephesians one three through 14.
So Ephesians one three through
14, again, one sentence.
Now if you thought that Collagen's
sentence was long, listen to this one.
Blessed be the God and father of our Lord
Jesus Christ who blessed us with every
spiritual blessing in
the heavenlies in Christ,
just as he chose us in him before
the foundation of the cosmos,
that we might be holy and blameless
in his presence and love having fore
ordained for us,
the sun ship or the adoption through
Jesus Christ for himself according to the
pleasure of his will,
for the praise of the glory of His grace,
which he granted us in the one he loves,
in whom we have the
washing through his blood,
the forgiveness of transgressions
according to the riches of His grace,
which he lavished on us in all wisdom
and prudence making known to us the
mystery of his will
according to his pleasure,
which he set forth previously in him
until the building up of the fullness of
the Times recapitulating
everything in Christ,
things in the heavens
and on the earth in him,
in whom also we have become heirs for
ordained according to the plant or the one
who accomplishes everything according
to the plan of his will so that we might
exist for the praise of his Glory.
We who were the first to hope in Christ,
in whom also you hearing the word of
truth, the announcement of your salvation,
and in whom also you believed you were
sealed with the promised Holy Spirit,
which is the seal of our inheritance
for the washing of the possession,
for the praise of his glory.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. It sounds like, um,
who the comedian George Carlin,
doesn't it?
It sounds like something George Carlin
would come with come up with and this
stringing together all
this stuff together.
That's actually one sentence in Greek.
It's 201 words by my last count.
Um,
or incidentally,
when I translate this into English,
it actually comes out to be 250
words in the English translation.
So that's a long sentence.
Now the,
that I do all that just to say this is
a good lesson. You should learn Greek.
You should learn Greek because it's
actually fun to fic to read some of these
texts in the original language because
the English translations change it enough
that you don't get the feel of it. You
can get the feel of it even in English.
If you sit there and read those,
that all those verses in first and
the first chapter of Ephesians,
just in your own English translation,
you'll notice you'll get some of that
rhythm because they try to maintain a
little bit of that long kind of feeling,
but you can't.
It's only a Greek that you figured
out that this is one sentence.
Now Paul is capable of writing
a complex sentence like that,
but he just doesn't.
You can search all the way through the
seven authentic letters of Paul and you
just tell, especially the Ephesians
passage, it just doesn't sound like Paul.
Paul writes fairly
straightforward sentences.
Sometimes they have grammatical problems.
Sometimes he kind of starts and stops.
Sometimes it's hard to figure out exactly,
you know grammatically how and
syntactically house in his words together,
but Paul's capable of writing
perfectly fine Greek sentences,
but Paul writes his letters almost more
the way you would expect somebody to
talk not like this,
which is very elaborate
and its construction. This,
this authors obviously working to make
an elaborate introductory sentence.
That's the first thing that's heard in
this congregation who's hearing this
letter read out loud.
So one of the first things that I would
say is I just don't think these letters
are by public because they
don't sound like Paul.
They don't sound like his style.
They're very,
very different as far as just the
style of the writing and the Greek.
Other people would say,
well there's also the vocabulary.
The vocabulary is quite a bit
different in collages and infusions.
Now there are some proof if you
noticed the collage sentence was long,
but it was not nearly as elaborate
as that Ephesians sentence. Right.
But if you notice they sounded similar
in places they both talk about the
heavenlies. It's kind of,
it's the plural for heaven.
So the heavens are the heavenly
places is this Greek word.
They both use that kind of
language as we'll go through.
They both [inaudible] look a lot alike,
both in their theology
and in their style and,
and even the structure of the two letters.
So were they written by the same person?
Some people think so.
Uh, some people say they think it's
more likely that Paul May have written
Colassians because it at least is not
so different from some of his other
letters. And then they'll say, but a
pseudonymous writer wrote Ephesians.
What I think is that collages were
written by one disciple of Paul.
He knew Pauline theology.
I think that he knew Paul CLG pretty well.
It's just that it's not
what he ends up teaching.
And Collagen's is not exactly
Paul's theology as I'll show today.
I think though that Ephesians was,
Kane came along and was written by
somebody else using Collagen's as a model.
And that's why I think if you get a
Fijian, she had this long, long, long,
long sentence that is longer than
the similar sentence and collages,
but seems to borrow some from it.
So I think a different
disciple came around knew that,
knew about the literal two collisions,
use collagenase is a model and then wrote
the letter to the Ephesians as another
on pseudonymous this letter.
So the way I'm going to teach this,
and this is something that some scholars
want to agree with me about obviously,
but I'm going to take the seven undisputed
letters of Paul as being by Paul
Collagen's. I teach is written by
one disciple of Paul using his, uh,
ideas, but elaborating them differently
and using a very different writing style.
And Ephesians was written by another
disciple of Paul using Colombians and
Paul's letters as models.
So what is the issue?
Let's start with Collagen's now.
What is the issue in Colombians
first I'll stop there.
Any questions or are a outburst
about what we've done so far?
Yes,
sir.
Okay.
The question is what says that the seven
that I've called the undisputed theirs
are actually Paul and the others are
not Paul. Uh, in other words, you, uh,
basically what it is is that you've got
to have something that you're willing to
say is Paul.
If you're ever going to say something
else is not Paul and the undisputed
letters, we just say that's the historical
Paul. There's just, if there's anything.
Now, of course there's a joke in
scholarship that basically says, well,
the seven letters that are the undisputed
is appalled by some called by that by
some scholars.
They weren't really written by Paul.
They were written by another
guy named Paul. You know, and
at some point you just have to say,
well,
we're going to pause it that there was
a historical Paul and if anything in the
Bible was written by that guy that we're
going to assume was a historical Paul,
it's those seven letters. They
have enough of the style, the same.
They cohere well together,
all seven of them.
Now that there are scholars who will
doubt some of those seven also one of more
than seven,
but it's sort of like somebody else said,
well I don't believe Romans and Galatians
were by Paul. Then I kind of say,
well then they're written by another
apostle who was named Paul and had the
exact same ideas and
the same writing style.
I mean I at some point you just have
to throw up your hands. But yes,
it's a good question.
Basically scholars just start off saying,
if there is a historical Paul,
then what are the letters that look enough
alight to form one body of literature
and those are those seven letters.
Any other questions? Okay,
let's look at Colossians now
and go through it and talk
about what's at issue in
collections and what does
this letter actually about.
Now I asked you to read
Collagen's before a fusions,
although it comes after in the Canon
Canon because I think Collagen's predates
Ephesians and instead of,
I mean you get basically had a choice.
These are similar enough in their style
and content that you sort of have to say
either the same person wrote both of them
and that's why they're so much alike.
Or if you say like I did that
different people wrote them,
one of them use the other as a model.
So I argue that Collagen's was first
and use the model by Ephesians because I
think it's more collages,
more elaborated in the Ephesians document.
But of course what Collagen's doesn't
come before Ephesians even though I'm
saying it was written before it. And why
does Collagen's come after Ephesians?
In the Canon. You should be able
to guess this now if you haven't,
we haven't already talked about it.
I think we talked about it
earlier in the semester.
Why does collages come after
Ephesians in the Canon?
Why does first Corinthians
come after Romans in the Canon?
Yeah,
you bet.
I want to make a guess.
How are the letters of Paul arranged
in the Canon by order? Sorry,
somebody said it. Length.
Exactly. That's right.
The longer letters are first
and they get shorter as you go.
So collagen's is shorter than Ephesians
and therefore it comes after a fusions
in the Canon, but that's just the
way the cannon got to be formed.
So let's look and see what's going on
here. And for this, what is the issue?
Let's look at the collage is two 16
yeah.
Therefore,
do not let anyone condemn you in matters
of food and drink or of observing
festivals. New Moons are sabbaths. These
are only a shadow of what is to come,
but the substance belongs to Christ.
Do not let anyone disqualify you.
Insisting on self-abasement and
worship of angels dwelling on visions,
puffed up without cars by a human way
of thinking and not holding fast to the
head from whom the whole body nourished
and held together by its ligaments and
sinews grows with the
growth that is from God a.
If with Christ you died to the
elemental spirits of the universe.
Remember those were those story chaos
we talked about in Galatians though the
elemental spirits of the universe.
Okay,
you died to the elemental
spirits of the universe.
Why do you live as if you
still belong to the world?
Why do you submit to regulations? Do
not handle, do not touch, do not taste,
do not touch. All these regulations
refer to things that parish with use.
They are simply human
commands and teachings.
These have indeed an appearance
of wisdom in self imposed piety,
humility and severe treatment of the body.
But they are of no value in checking
self indulgence. So what's going on here?
This is basically some form of asceticism.
The control of the body.
Asceticism comes from the
Greek word for exercise.
And ascetic is someone
who disciplines the body.
So asceticism refers to usually the
avoidance of something like food or
luxurious foods or sex or anything
that has desire. Passion is part of it.
So apparently this author's writing
to a community that's been bothered by
people who are teaching certain forms of
self control and discipline of the body,
the worship of angels.
Now there's a debate about whether this
refers to people worshiping angels or
whether it refers to people who think
they're joining with angels in the worship
of God.
I think it must refer to
people who believe they're
worshiping angels and cause
this all this all does linked that
to steroid chaos of the universe.
I think what the author is doing is
something that Paul sort of did too,
which is somehow equate in a sense these
store Kayah of the universe with an
angels who try to manipulate
things on the earth and below us.
So I think that there's,
I'll just probably referring to is that
somebody come along and is teaching.
Some churches have Paul Paul's churches
to do some elaborate sort of ascetic
practices to gain some kind
of great spiritual status.
Maybe these people are teaching
you live on the earth now,
but if you want to fly up through the
different regions of the heavens member,
there are several different layers
of heavens and ancient cosmology.
If you want to fly up through
the different layers of heavens,
then you have to stop eating meat.
You have to stop having sex.
You need to enjoy it in this
worship of the angels. Why?
Because angels control there,
the gateways to all these
different layers of heaven.
So what's going on is some aspect of
asceticism is being talked to these people
and some of them seem to be getting
into it. What is the answer?
This author gives one 19 four in him
that is in Christ is collages one 19 all
the fullness of God was pleased to
dwell and through him God was pleased to
reconcile to himself all things,
whether on earth or in heaven,
by making peace through the blood of
his cross and look at three one through
four. So, in other words,
what's the author says is you don't
need all these ascetic practices.
Because if you are in Christ,
you already possess everything
that the heavens have to offer.
You don't need these extra practices.
So he says in chapter three verse one
if you have been raised with Christ,
oh,
that's interesting.
He's basically attributing
the resurrection already
to these people's current
state.
Now maybe he's talking about baptism.
Maybe the idea is that in your baptism,
when you go down to the water,
I remember in ancient baptism, they all
dunked him like good baptist these days,
not a little sprinkling and stuff.
They dunked him in the water.
So if you go down in the water,
like you're being buried,
you come up out of water and that's
like you're being raised from the grave.
So he may be talking about
if you've been baptized,
you had been raised with Christ already.
If you've been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where
Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above,
not on things that are on
earth for you have died.
He's talking about these people is that
they've already experienced death and
your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life is revealed,
then you also will be
revealed with him in glory.
So this author basically saying,
you don't need these different practices
because you already perhaps in your
baptism have experienced
death and resurrection.
The only thing these people haven't
experienced that they will experience in
heaven according this author is simply
the revelation of their glory. Yeah,
they're still leather workers
and waitresses and you know,
working in the query. So it, they
don't look like kings. Right now,
their skin doesn't glow,
but when Christ is revealed,
then their skin will glow and all
their neighbors will go, oh my God,
I thought you were just a waiter.
Now I see that you're
living in glory in heaven.
So that's the only thing they have.
All all that you would
possess in the heavens.
This author says you already possess.
Now compare this with Paul.
Keep your finger and Colombians
and go back to Romans six
what then are we to say?
And I remember in Romans,
Paul is defending himself against charges
that he has been antinomian. No law,
just anything goes, do anything
you want to do. What are we to say?
Should we continue in sin in order
that Grace May abound? By no means.
How can we who died to
sin go on living in it.
Do you not know that all of us who have
been baptized into Christ Jesus were
baptized into his death?
So Paul is Christians have
also been bad ties into death.
Therefore we have been buried
with him by baptism into death.
So that just as Christ was raised from
the dead by the glory of the father.
So we also have been raised from death.
Huh?
Oh, I like sheep. No, that's not
what it says. I'm lying to you.
That's why I want you
to read along with me.
That's the way most modern
Christians read that passage though.
They take the Collagen's
account that has the,
the author kind of acts like they've
been not only buried in baptism but also
risen in baptism and they take that
clot and read it back into Roman six but
that's not what Paul says in Romans six
he doesn't say they have been raised yet.
Christians have been buried,
but then he says,
so we too might walk in newness of life.
That's not happened yet called Paul.
If we have been United with
him in a death like his,
we will certainly be United
with him in a like his for Paul,
the resurrection of Christians
hasn't happened yet.
Christians were Paul or living in this,
in between state,
haven't been bad ties him to death,
but not having been raised yet.
We know that our old self was crucified
with him so that the body of sin might
be destroyed and we might no longer be
enslaved to him for whoever has died is
freed from sin. So there are
some of these things like that.
But basically for Paul in Baptism,
you participate in the death
and burial Christ, but it's all,
you don't yet participant
in the resurrection.
Notice that's quite different
from what you find a Colombians.
Colombians pulls the resurrection that
for is still in the future and he puts it
into presence in the present.
This is called by scholars
realized eschatology.
What's eschatology?
Somebody say it.
Sorry.
The end of the world doctrine about
the end of the world document.
The last things Eschaton is the
Greek word for the end or the last.
So eschatology is what do you
believe about the last things,
how things are going to end up realized.
Eschatology basically is
the term we scholars good.
This is not Paul's term or the
other, uh, any other ancient writer.
The idea that the eschatological
expectations that Paul
expected to happen at
the end of this world is,
has already been realized
in the lives of the church.
So what Paul has is not realized as
Catala g because the resurrection and all
the benefits that you get from being a
saved by Christ are still in the future.
So let's just call that reserved
eschatology
Torres in Paul's letters,
it's very important for Paul's theology
that the end hasn't happened yet.
The resurrection hasn't happened yet.
The resurrection of Christ has happened.
But member Paul says he's just the first
fruits of those who sleep the first
fruit. He's the first apple on the
tree. That's Christ's resurrection.
But all the rest of us are just a little
apple blossoms are a little immature
apples.
We haven't gotten to maturity yet.
We have to wait until either Jesus comes
back in the pair of Sia or we die and
resurrect our resurrected at the end.
So collagen's has a realized eschatology
and Paul has a reserved eschatology,
and this is one of the major theological
difference between the Paul's
undisputed letters and Collagen's that
some of us scholars grasp onto to say
it's not palling. Now, other
people would say, no, no, no.
Paul just was emphasizing different
things when he wrote collages because the
situation was different.
He changed his writing style a bit because
he was writing to a different group
and you wanted to have a more elevated
style. He changed his eschatology a bit,
emphasized current enjoyment of these
things because of the different situation.
That's one way to read this. So some
people say either Paul's views changed.
Are apologists, emphasize different
aspects of theology. If you want to say,
Paul wrote Collagen's and there
are many scholars who do I say, no,
this is good evidence that we're talking
about a different author who has a
slightly different theology.
Uh,
that would be in some
ways pretty fundamentally
different like Paul was doing
though.
Notice how like these these people are
doing what Paul's people in Galatians did
their trip.
They're looking for something else to
add onto the requirements of faith that
will somehow guarantee their possession
of the blessings of salvation.
This author though provides a
different answer. Paul's answer.
What was Paul's answer to
people in Galatians who
wanted to add on circumcision
and kosher? He basically said,
no, you are actually nullifying.
The faithfulness of God.
Justification for Paul in
Romans has always been by faith.
Even Abraham was justified by faith,
not by circumcision.
And so Paul makes a big argument saying,
justification has always been by faith,
therefore nothing else
can be added on to it.
And this is part important
for Paul because that Jay,
that's God's faithfulness for Paul.
The most important thing is if God
wasn't always justifying people by faith,
that would mean God changed his mind
and what God was not faithful to the
original covenant to Abraham. So no
for Paul, God justified by faith.
He always has justified by faith
even all the way back to Abraham,
the Collagen's rider doesn't
it a bit differently.
He also talks about faith that's
important to him, but basically he says,
you don't need all these additions
because you already possess them.
You've already experienced
the resurrection of Jesus.
You already sit in the heavenly places
and therefore you don't need these other
things.
Now,
Ephesians uses [inaudible] as a model
and then just build on it even more.
So let's look over to Ephesians.
Yeah.
And Look at Ephesians one 20
God put this power to work in Christ when
he raised him from the dead and seated
him at his right hand
in the heavenly places,
far above all rule and authority and
power and dominion and above every name
that is named not only in this
age but also in the age to come.
He has put all things under his feet and
made him the head over all things for
the church, which is his body, the
fullness of him who fills all in all.
So Christ is already now
seated in the heavenly places,
which he is for Paul Theology too.
But what's makes it different is
look at two six chapter two verse six
and raised us up with him.
So again,
the resurrection is something the
Ephesians rider says they've already
experienced and seated us with him in
the heavenly places in Christ Jesus.
So that in the ages to come he might
show the immeasurable richness,
riches of his grace and kindness
toward us in Christ Jesus.
So already now notice verse eight of
Chapter Two for by grace you have been
saved through faith. And this is your
own doing. It is the gift of God.
Now that's something that
you might not notice,
but scholars like to pick on little
things like that and most scholars would
point out that if you look,
just pause seven undisputed letters.
Salvation is something that
for Paul exists in the future.
Justification is something that
you've experienced in the past.
So Paul can say you have been justified,
but Paul almost never acts like
Christians have been saved.
So for example, when someone knocks
on your door and someone says,
have you been saved? You can say, well no,
because the apostle Paul reserves
salvation for the end time.
I've been justified but I haven't
been saved. That's good. Paul.
Line theology, the people who
talk about have you been saved?
They're using theology from
Ephesians perhaps or from Colassians,
but it doesn't really fit Paul's
theology for PR per policy.
Ology justification is
something you've experienced,
but salvation is something you still
have to wait on. For Ephesians though,
salvation is something you have
experienced through faith. Notice it.
Ephesians therefore actually looks
like it's using collage as an example.
It has some of the same themes,
some of the same styles,
but Ephesians is actually looks even
more like a treatise and not like a real
letter. If you outline Ephesians,
you get the first three chapters,
which are very elaborate
doctrinal teachings about
what Christ has accomplished,
what you, if you're a follower
of Christ, have experienced.
And one of the main focuses of
Ephesians is that gentiles and Jews,
the whole world has been joined into
one humanity in the body of Christ.
So the dividing wall of hostility
between Jews and gentiles,
we represent probably the law in this
guy's thinking has been broken down and
all followers of Christ
have experienced this.
But the first three letters do that.
And then chapters four
through six in Ephesians,
look more like a section on ethics.
Or as scholars will often say,
para nieces.
This is just a fancy ankus
ization of a Greek word,
which means instruction
or moral instruction. It's
shock when your mom says,
do this. Don't do that. Behave yourself.
Don't pick your nose at the table,
you know, say, excuse me, when you burp.
So there's a lot of Christian material
that are seen as sort of do this,
don't do that ethics and that's what the
last half of Ephesians looks more like.
So scholars often say Ephesians
looks like a very nice treatise,
a very well organized outline of
Christian doctrine and teaching.
The first half of it being doctrine
and the second half of it being ethics,
but now there's, I won't go into
this much, but why do I say that?
The fetus was written by a different
author and not simply the same author and
there's really just one reason and this
was argued by a young man, Jeremy Holton,
who teaches in the divinity school here
and he did a phd here at Yale several
years ago. The Phd was mainly on
foul language in early Christianity.
What counts as cousin,
what counts is dirty language and why
both co the Ephesians and Colossians talks
about don't use the Turman Greek as
I scroll a Ghia, shameful speech.
Well Jeremy kind of sat there and
thought, well nick, when I was a kid,
my mom won't let us say, darn, we were
really strict. You certainly couldn't say,
Dang, that was worse than darn and
dam was worse than any of them.
So don't get caught saying,
damn,
now I've actually caught my mother
saying it a few times lately.
But things change.
But what makes you know damn
bad for some people in darn.
Okay, well these are cultural differences,
right? Why is it that in some cultures,
body parts,
certain body parts or excrement is
considered a foul word that you're not
suppose to say in polite company.
Why is it that some cultures have curse
words and some of those curse words are
related to sacred things?
Like why in some cultures is considered
bad language and offensive offensive
language to say Jesus Christ,
especially when you say Jesus h Christ.
Whereas in other cultures,
calling on the name of a god or a
goddess wouldn't be considered shameful
language at all. So Jeremy said, what
these people mean by shameful language.
How do you know shameful language when
you see it in the ancient world and what
were they talking about?
So his dissertation is on that.
But one thing he points out is that
although both the writer of Collagen's and
Ephesians tell people not
to use shameful language,
the writer of Colombians actually
tells people in his church to use witty
language. He says, if your
translation, it may say something like,
let your speech be seasoned with salt.
And Jeremy pointed out that this is
where it ever hurts to Wiki language,
to language of wit.
The writer to the Collegians Ephesians
condemns that kind of language.
So he just noticed that these two
writers are very similar in some ways,
but when it comes down to what
counts is shameful speech.
The writer to the Ephesians considered
shameful speech even to include
witticisms making jokes that also
was considered shameful speech.
Whereas the rider to the Colombians
doesn't include that in tech.
He tells people to use wit
in their language. So that's,
that's just, uh, one of the reasons
before that I kind of thought, well,
probably the same person
wrote both these uh,
letters and they were just
different in some ways.
But he convinced me that quite probably
they were written by two different,
very similar,
but two different followers of Jesus
with the collage as being the earlier
letter and the Ephesians writer using
collage as a model and then capitalizing
on. Another interesting thing is we don't
really know whether the letter to the
Ephesians was written to the Ephesians.
There's an interesting problem
in the Greek manuscripts.
A lot of Greek manuscripts
don't have to the Ephesians.
Some of them have
another place name there,
and some of them seem
to have just a blank.
This has led some scholars to say maybe
Ephesians was written as a circular
letter. In fact, some
people have even said,
maybe Ephesians was written
when a collection of Paul's
letters we've made and
some scriber editor decided,
well,
I'm going to write an introductory
letter that will be kind of encapsulate
Paul's Gospel and Paul's message, and
I'm gonna do it in a very elevated style,
and we'll put that at the beginning
of the collection to sort of be a,
an introductory letter for all
the collection of Paul's letters.
But one of the things is we think that
Ephesians may have been a circular letter
because of this idea that not all the
Greek manuscripts have Ephesians and some
have other things.
So the idea is that the guy may have
written a letter with the idea that you
would leave to the blank and then
fill it in with different place names
according to where you're going to send
the letter or that you would send it one
place and then they can
fill in another lang,
let name and send it to other places.
So Ephesians by in many of our reckoning
is may have been written as a circular
letter intended to be circulated
around different churches,
maybe even as sort of an introductory
letter to a collection of Paul's other
letters. What though are the
other developments, and here's,
I'm going to close with
just a few minutes here.
What makes these letters different
from Pauline Christianity?
And there are a few things. Number
one, I sought collage in Ephesians.
Both have realized eschatology.
Paul has reserved as [inaudible].
In other words,
for Paul,
all the enjoyments that Christians
would have experienced are still in the
future.
It's like for Paul,
the blessings of the eschatology.
Eschatology is still horizontal.
We're here, we're going there,
we're on earth, will be in heaven.
We've experienced death.
We will experience resurrection
for a theme than Collagen's.
They've taken this axis
and turn it like this,
so that the things that there's the
cosmos and there's the heavenlies,
but they all still exist right now.
So the rest of the world
is down here on earth.
But followers of Jesus had been translated
already right now into the heavenly
places and they already
enjoy these benefits.
So it's almost as if the
eschatological timeline,
the axis in Paul's letters have been
just flipped up like this and collages in
Ephesians.
So that's one major difference.
Another major difference is colossus
in Ephesians have a slightly higher
Christology. The collages
writer, very famous,
he says in Christ, the entire
fullness of God was pleased to dwell.
Paul never says anything quite like that.
In fact,
Paul's letters are kind of problematic
from a good Orthodox theological point of
view because Paul seems to assume what
we would later call a subordinationism
Christology. Subordination,
his Christology,
which was declared heretical by the
time you get to the creeds in the fourth
century says that Jesus is another person
separate from God the father and Jesus
is inferior to God the father.
So Jesus is subordinate to God the father.
And there are several
passages in Paul's letters.
One of them in First Corinthians 15 that
we've talked about in red in this class
already, where policy seems to still
believe that God, the father is here,
Christ is here.
I know it was his first Corinthians 11
where Paul Paul talks about man is the
head of woman. Christ is the head of
man and God is the head of Christ.
Well, that's a hierarchy.
God Christ, man, woman.
So Paul seems to hold
what we would call us up.
Almost a subordination
is form of Christology,
whereas the collage and in Ephesians
tend to have Christ as more fully God.
Then another the changes,
and I won't go into this too much,
but if you look at the household codes,
we'll get to this later when we talk
about Christianity and the family
in collage in f Collagen's
three 18 through 41 and
Ephesians five 21 through six
nine you have an elaborate set of
rules for the head of the household,
the wife, the children, the slaves,
everybody has their job to do in collages.
In Ephesians,
there is clearly a patriarchal
household structure that's hierarchical.
The wives and the children submit to
the husband, the father, the slave,
submit to the master.
This is much more hierarchical impro
household than what you get empowered
authentic letters. Paul is perfectly
willing to kind of be have women and men,
husbands, wives, more mutual,
which he says in First Corinthians seven
the husband controls the wife's body,
but the wife also controls
the husband's body.
They beat you have authority over each
other's body. That's not the way it is.
And collages in Ephesians where
it's much more hierarchical,
much more patriarchal.
So there are some kinds of differences,
but what does it say about
Paul already by these letters?
Then by these pseudonymous letters we
have Paul being thought of now as a figure
in the past whose reputation can not be
built on to advance a slightly different
version of the Christian
Gospel and Christian message.
Then you got in Paul's letters,
Paul is already starting to recede into
the past now and it will as we'll see as
the semester goes on,
we'll read other texts that have Paul
even further in the past and then he can
be drawn on to justify or promote
another form of early Christianity.
Any questions about that?
Next time what we'll do is we'll look
at the letter of James in which we have
someone who may indeed be actually
opposing Paul's Gospel and Paul's message
rather than just building on it.
See you next time.